la communication gérald darmanin elle
est partiale et partielle vous voit bien
que la prise de parole n'a qu'un seul
but c'est de défendre une version et
cette version c'est celle du
gouvernement
ce qui a été constaté c'est une fraude
massive
industriel est organisé de faux billets
la présence massive de ces faux billets
est effectivement le mâle racines qui a
causé les reports par trois fois du
commencement du match et si on n'avait
pas évacué une partie parfois
effectivement avec des moyens difficile
à voir à la télévision il y aurait eu
sans doute des morts normalement on
considère qu'une bonne communication de
crise est celle qui permet tout et sur
trois leviers c'est à dire que la preuve
de réactivité de transparence et
d'empathie on voit bien que gérald
darmanin part du principe qu'il n'y
aurait qu'une seule cause à tout ce qui
s'est passé au stade de france en droit
on pourrait parler de causalité unis
plus de causalité allez quoi toute son
argumentation et toutes sont le style
qui va essayer de développer ne va être
délicat c'est à un seul objectif c'est
de trouver la clé raciste et de cette
thèse et ça on le voit bien par les
effets de manche qui l'utilisent que ce
soit par des rythmes ternaires ou alors
par des effets de manche quand il fait
devant les caméras de tf1 une
insinuation en dix ans là il se trouve
que des clubs de foot notamment
liverpool ont demandé l'intégralité de
leurs billets en papier c'est un peu
étonnant on s'en étonne si on regarde
nationalité la moitié des
interpellations à vert-saint-denis au
stade de france étaient les britanniques
nous constatons que comme en 2010 9 à
madrid avec liverpool il ya eu les mêmes
problèmes malheureusement il ya un lien
parfois avec certains supporters pas
tous britanniques et ce qui s'est passé
ce soir nationale les supporteurs de
liverpool seraient les seuls
responsables de ce qui est arrivé est de
dire en fait par un raisonnement qui est
extrêmement simpliste que s'il n'y avait
pas eu ce problème il n'y aurait eu
aucun problème donc
comportement des organisations et faux
billets organisée avec notamment je le
rappelle l'entraîneur de liverpool qu'il
ya quelques jours c'est public a appelé
à venir en france le supporters même non
munis de billets et une partie infime
mais malheureusement extrêmement vivante
si je dire qui a bousculé le système de
sécurité c'est parce que nous avons une
tactique de madge l'ordre qui je crois
est proportionné qui a permis d'éviter
ses morts et ses blessés ce type de
raisonnement déjà lui totalement la
communication crise et surtout on voit
bien qu'il n'ya aucune empathie dans les
messages qui sont envoyées aux
supporteurs de liverpool il faut
beaucoup plus de prudence et beaucoup
plus d'empathie dans la manière créative
auprès du public la faute originelle
c'est celle qui a été commise par gérald
darmanin qui dès samedi soir à créer un
puits pour désigner ou pointer du doigt
les supporteurs britanniques à partir de
ce moment là toute la communication
où toute la rhétorique ne poursuit qu'un
seul but c'est de convaincre d'une fête
qu'ils n'étaient justifiés de dénoncer
les supporteurs britanniques dès samedi
soir
le haut prélat
on verra
évidemment ce grameen a une résonance
particulière en termes de communication
par stx et ico à la catastrophe
d'hillsborough qui déjà avait avec des
très gros guillemets impliquer les
supporteurs de liverpool c'est une
catastrophe qui avait causé la mort de
dizaines de personnes à l'occasion d'un
match qui se déroulait avec des fans de
liverpool et tout de suite on se
souvient que le gouvernement britannique
avait accusé les supporter d'être les
seuls responsables de la situation et il
a fallu de très longues années et même
des décennies et les travaux
parlementaires pour qu'enfin le
gouvernement britannique concède avoir
comique d'abord une erreur en termes de
maintien de l'ordre vous imaginez 40000
spectateurs britanniques sans billet
plus et 22000 qui eux avaient l'ordre et
billets ça fait plus de 60 mille
spectateurs britanniques qui étaient
arrivés avec des vrais ou des faux
billets la bonne communication de crise
aurait été celle qui au fond on cherche
tout d'abord à établir des vérités et à
dire ce que l'on sait et ce que l'on ne
sait pas et c'est très suspect si vous
voulez dès lundi matin de pouvoir
arriver en mettant tout de suite une
seule cause de responsabilité alors que
le plus souvent dans ce genre
d'événement il ya plusieurs causes il ya
plusieurs responsabilités
la démarche dans laquelle le ministère
de l'intérieur s'inscrit c'est celui
presque barbier de confirmation il
rappelle d'ailleurs malheureusement que
liverpool tottenham en 2010 nurse à
madrid a posé et le temps les mêmes
problèmes une finale à wembley il ya
quelques années de ça on pose exactement
les mêmes problèmes nous partons ou
d'une thèse et nous allons essayer de
trouver dans les faits tous les éléments
qui permettent de justifier ce qui était
la base principale notre thèse
principale à savoir que les problèmes
viennent des supporteurs britanniques
tout l'édifice tout le château de cape
pourrait assez rapidement et assez
facilement s'est écroulé et parce que
nous avons une technique de maintien de
l'ordre et qui je crois est proportionné
non mais évidemment d image déplorable
des utilisations qui n'ont pas été
proportionnée donc évidemment l'occasion
le préfet de police et moi même dire que
le regretter et qu'évidemment on prendra
contact avec un maximum de ces personnes
pour nous en excuser bien évidemment la
communication de gérald darmanin elle
est partiale et partielle c'est à dire
qu'elles visent principalement à une
chose c'est défend d'administration que
représentent ses râles permanent et
c'est là on voit bien que dans ce
rapport qui très ambivalents la vérité
il va y avoir des flec qui vont être
défendus mais en apportant une partie de
la réalité voulu partie de la vérité on
ne défend jamais en tout cas très
rarement toute la vérité dans sa
complexité dans son ensemble
[Musique]